قطن خفيف الوزن ونظيف
وربما ترتديه الآن ولكن
لا تشعر بالراحة عندما
تعرف كيف تم صنعه ،
تتم زراعة معظم قطن العالم في البلدان التي تستخدم
عمالة الأطفال أو العمالة القسرية حيث يُجبر
الناس على العمل  رغماً عنهم على
سبيل المثال في الهند ، ثاني أكبر مزارع للقطن في العالم ،
يعمل العديد من
الأطفال في صناعة حلقة epcot ،
حيث يمكنهم العمل لمدة تصل إلى 12 ساعة في اليوم في
درجات حرارة شديدة تحمل
حمولات ثقيلة ويتعرضون لمبيدات الآفات ،
والمشكلة ليست فقط في زراعة القطن  تستخدم
أكبر الدول المصدرة للملابس في
العالم عمالة الأطفال أو العمالة القسرية
في صناعة الملابس الخاصة بهم ، ما الذي يمكن أن يستخدم
لشراء الملابس المعتمدة من التجارة العادلة
لمعرفة المزيد عن
العبودية الحديثة انضمت إلى CNN في يوم الحرية الخاص بي في
40 مارس